Ніхто не любить ані голок, ані вакцин,
але кращого способу убезпечитись від інфекційних хвороб поки не вигадали.
Усі вакцини, необхідні для імунізації згідно з календарем щеплень, в Україні є.
Про це заявила виконувачка обов’язків міністра охорони здоров’я Уляна Супрун.
Графік того, проти чого і коли треба колотися українцям,
висить на сайті міністерства охорони здоров'я у вільному доступі.
Йдеться не про всі можливі вакцини та сироватки.
Приміром, вакцини від грипу до цього переліку не належать.
Мова лише про обов'язкові щеплення від десяти найстрашніших інфекційних хвороб:
гепатиту В, кору, краснухи та свинки, дифтерії, правця та кашлюку,
поліомієліту, туберкульозу та гемофільної інфекції.
Усі їх треба робити дітям: з перших днів народження і аж до шістнадцяти років.
А дорослим - поновлювати вакцини від дифтерії та правця щодесять років.
На доказ того, що усі суспензії та порошки для ін'єкцій є в наявності,
міністерство надає таблицю по областях: скільки саме вакцин є у Києві та в кожному регіоні України,
окрім непідконтрольних частин Донеччини і Луганщини та окупованого Криму.
Найбільше - для профілактики дифтерії і правця - 4,5 мільйона вакцин на всю державу.
Загалом же від 10-ти найстрашніших хвороб існує запас в майже 14,5 мільйона вакцин.
Кожному з понад сорока мільйонів українців вакцини не замовляють,
а лише тим, хто їх потребує згідно з календарем щеплень.
В Україні досі немає централізованої системи обліку пацієнтів,
тому уряд надсилав запити в області, скільки вакцин потрібно на місцях,
і відповідну кількість закуповував.
Тому через спалах кору 2017 року вакцини довелось терміново дозамовляти і привозити.
А вже цьогоріч міністерство охорони здоров'я почало розробляти
нову методику розрахунку попиту.
Усі цi вакцини закуповуються за кошти держбюджету,
тому повинні робитися безкоштовно і дітям, і дорослим.
Тож якщо вам кажуть, що вакцини немає, слід йти до головного лікаря,
і якщо він не допоможе - дзвонити в місцеве управління охорони здоров'я
або у Київ, на гарячу лінію міністерства.
При цьому рівень щеплень в Україні - жахаюче низький.
За даними Всесвітньої організації охорони здоров'я,
минулоріч вакцини отримали менше половини усіх дітей - 31-40 відсотків,
приблизно стільки ж і у 2016 році.
По всій країні лише половина населення має щеплення від дифтерії та правця.
Хоча для підтримки колективного імунітету суспільства
вакцинація має бути на рівні 90-95 відсотків.
Проте багато батьків бояться ускладнень, неякісних матеріалів
або просто є прихильниками антивакцинального руху.
І замість того, щоб отримати безкоштовні вакцини, купують в лікарів довідки про те,
що їхня дитина отримала імунопрофілактику.
І в міністерстві охорони здоров'я, й опитані DW фахівці заявляють,
що всі ці вакцини є якісними, ефективними та безпечними.
Оплачує їх український уряд, але замовляє ЮНІСЕФ - дитячий фонд ООН,
який обирає лише ті вакцини, які відповідають вимогам Всесвітньої організації охорони здоров'я.
Так, зараз українцям закуповують вакцини з Франції, США, Кореї, Бельгії, Болгарії та Індії.
Заява виконувачки обов’язків міністра охорони здоров’я Уляни Супрун про те,
що в Україні є достатньо вакцин, відповідає дійсності.
Хоча якісному плануванню закупівель вакцин
заважає відсутність загальнонаціональної бази даних пацієнтів.
При цьому можливістю імунізувати дітей користуються менше половини українських батьків,
а рівень захисту населення України від можливих епідемій залишається вкрай низьким.